بدأت في النزول
بأعراض وفرصة وسيارة ، وفي يوم السبت
تطور هذا النوع من ضيق
التنفس في أواخر شهر مارس ، وعلى
الرغم من أن كارل فيديل البالغ من العمر 46 عامًا هو
طبيب أسرة ، إلا أنه لم يكن
قلقًا للغاية في البداية عندما كان  عاد
من رحلة شعرنا بالمرض ، اعتقدنا
أنه قد اتصل بالفعل بنوع من
الفيروسات الغريبة د.  روس بريمنر هو
جراح والمدير التنفيذي لمركز
سانت.  جوزيف snortin الصدري
في فينيكس أريزونا وأنت تعلم في
فترة قصيرة جدًا من الوقت أنه
أصيب بمرض مميت أن الانخفاض المفاجئ هو
شيء سمعنا عنه
مرارًا وتكرارًا الأشعة السينية التي تنتقل من الشكل هذا إلى
الشكل هذا
د.  تمكن فيدال من التواصل مع
عائلته قبل أن يتم وضع أنبوب التنفس ،
تم تخديرك بوضوح من
خلال هذا ولكن في وقت ما
يبدو أن هذا لم يكن كافيًا لأنك تعلم أن
أكسجة الغشاء خارج الجسم من ECMO
فكر في الأمر كنوع من الرئة الاصطناعية
أخيرًا  تلجأ عندما تصبح الرئتان
متيبستين للغاية بحيث لا تستطيعان العمل ،
ثم يتم ضخ الدم من الجسم
بحيث يزيل الدم المؤكسج
ثاني أكسيد الكربون ثم يعيد ذلك
إلى الأذين الأيمن للقلب
ويسمح لرئتي بالراحة والشفاء و  ثم قم
بتزويد جسدي بالأكسجين وإنقاذ حياتي بشكل أساسي ،
هل تعتقد أنك لن
تعيش بدونه.
كل الدم من الجسم
يزيد من خطر التجلط
وكذلك خطر النزيف من دمه
، وقد أصيب لاحقًا
بنزيف كبير من مجرى الهواء أيضًا  كما
قد تتخيل ، لم يكن أي من هذا سهلاً
بالنسبة له لمدة 55 يومًا في
هاكت ، فقد خمسة وخمسون رطلاً من وزني
منذ أسبوعين ، لا يمكنني أن أعطي إبهامًا لك
الآن
قوتي تعود ببطء ولكن
بالتأكيد نعم إذا كنت قد فعلت ذلك  أمشي بضع مجموعات
من السلالم ،
فأنا أحصل على تعويض قليل وأنا
أتطلع إلى هذا  أنت
تعلم كيف تشق الطريق إلى الأمام
[تصفيق]